[Music]  this world is not yet ready for all that  you will do  the time will come diana  and everything will be different  [Music]  citizens of the world i'm here to change  your life  anything you want  anything you dream of you can have it  look like you saw ghost  diana lucky you it's like now one day  has passed  i don't want to be like anyone i want to  be an  apex predator  you've always had everything while  people like me have had nothing  well now that's my turn  get used to it  i've never been one for rules the answer  is always  more  the way i fly they will never find us i  forgot to tell you what  radar will they will they shoot at us  [Applause]  [Music]  barbara what did you do  you know i'm not so keen on this one i  figure uh you are but  you know what i'm ready to go i think we  can do better  parachute pants yeah um does everybody  parachute now  [Music]  you